foreign
[Music]
you will learn how to troubleshoot and
resolve throttling jobs in data proc on
compute engine clusters to begin let's
look at what a data product job is it is
a program or a script you want to run on
a dataproc cluster typically to perform
processing of data you can submit a job
using Google Cloud console Google Cloud
CLI API or login directly into the
primary virtual machine or VM through
SSH keep in mind a dataproc job is not
same as a yarn application rather a job
can be made up of one or more yarn
applications when a job is stuck in
running State and lacking the resources
it needs for Progress the master VM
throttles or delays the job before
diving into troubleshooting a throttle
job let's understand the life of a data
proc job as soon as a job is submitted
it gets into the pending state it
remains in the state until the data
agent acquires it if the dataproc agent
acquires the job then it gets into the
running State sometimes a job may not be
acquired due to failure in the agent
compute engine Network or some other
calls then the state of the job is set
as error once the job is in running
State the data proc agent then checks
for resources to make sure the job
driver can process it this is a crucial
step since the resources can vary on
many parameters like concurrent running
jobs memory CPU consumption size of
cluster Etc if the resources are not
available the job is throttled or
delayed and its state is set as skewed
otherwise the job spins up drivers and
applications progresses and finally
exits upon completion let's now get into
action and learn how to troubleshoot and
resolve a data product job that took
seven times longer to finish than normal
I'll start with Google Google Cloud
console but it doesn't give any other
clue or information on what caused this
delay so I'll check the status of the
job in Google Cloud CLI by running the
gcloud dataproc jobs describe command
check the status history it shows that
the job was in running state for longer
than expected recall from the discussion
on life of a data proc job that if a job
is in running state it means that the
dataproc agent had acquired the job and
moved it to the running State however
the job could have been throttled due to
lack of resources to investigate this
issue further let's check if there was a
high resource consumption when the job
was running go to Cloud monitoring and
use the filter to view the CPU
utilization for the duration when the
job was running well it all looks good
next step is to analyze the dataproc
agent logs as it contains the progress
logs of the jobs let's go to the log
Explorer page and use this filter to
view the errors and warnings for
specific job ID and cluster set the time
interval to the duration in which the
job is running
there you go the cluster complains of
being throttled for too many jobs
expand the details to drill down the
metadata
ah it says maximum one job allowed which
seems to be the cause for this issue
this means that only one job can be run
at a time since there are many jobs
running simultaneously the job will be
throttled and hence the delay in
completion to validate this let's check
the cluster configuration this can be
done by capturing the Diagnostics file
using the following diagnose command
remember this file should be collected
while the cluster still exists
navigate to the conf folder and open the
data proc
dataproc.properties file indeed dataproc
Max concurrent jobs is set to 1. this is
the cause of the issue to resolve the
issue increase the max concurrent jobs
by setting a higher value to
scheduler.max concurrent jobs property
remember if this value is not set when
the cluster is created the upper limit
on concurrent jobs is calculated using
this formula Master memory MB is
determined by the primary vm's machine
type mesh memory mb per job is 1024 by
default and is configurable at cluster
Creation with scheduler driver size MB
property alternatively you can set the
property scheduler driver size MB to a
higher value this property determines
the maximum number of concurrent jobs a
cluster will run keep in mind if both
Max concrete jobs and driver-sized
memory are configured the max concurrent
jobs takes precedent consider upgrading
your cluster to a bigger machine size if
more capacity is required it is helpful
to note that a dataproc job can get
throttled if the primary agent fails to
acquire the resources due to any of the
additional reasons other issues like
increased data volume dependency
resolution can also make your data
product job throttled the tools that we
covered in this video should be a good
start for your investigation stay tuned
for more videos to troubleshoot failed
jobs on dataproc for more information
about troubleshooting throttle jobs
check out the following documentation
thanks for watching foreign
[Music]